hello everyone and welcome to some
important news from the candidates
tournament 2024 we are not going to
spill the beans just yet first let's
check out the game as it is a very
important one for this particular topic
gkes has the white pieces and he opens
with Pon to E4 his opponent French
Grandmaster Jil M replies with paon to
E5 uh Knight to F3 Knight to F6 and now
Knight captures on E5 going for the
classical variation of the pet D6 and
Knight back to F3 Knight captures on E4
and now standard is to go for for D4 but
Gish goes Knight to C3 he wants to play
for a win and he goes for this Knight to
C3 line which offers white very
interesting options Knight captures and
C3 D captures and now Bishop to E7 if
you are uh if you are interested in
playing this Knight to C3 line sometimes
the black will play Bishop to G4 against
you which is a really bad move uh
because you can just attack it and then
after he moves the bishop to H5 because
he wants to control this diagonally if
he just moves the bishop back then he
lost the tempo and if he plays this then
you play Queen D5 you attack B7 and his
Bishop he will have to capture and you
will have one uh the bishop pair and you
will have an excellent game so that's
something that you need to know if you
play this line uh you know uncertain
levels this happens quite often so
Bishop to E7 of course this is the top
level uh Bishop to E3 we have castles
and now Queen to D2 preparing Queens
side castles Knight to D7 and queens
side castles we have Knight to F6 uh
Bishop to D3 so far uh all all of these
are top moves been played many many
times Rook to E8 uh and here usually
they continue with some like Rook H to
E1 uh there's even a game where Rook to
G1 was played some H3 H4 moves are known
also King to B1 is a known move but here
we have Pawn to A3 and it is now as of
move 11 that we have a completely new
game so okay Jill replies with Pawn to
D5 grabs more space in the center now
the Bishops are uh free to roam the
board Rook H to E1 and now Bishop to G4
we have H3 uh Gish allows the doubling
of the Pawns in order to open up the G
file to attack the black king and that's
exactly what happens Bishop captures G
captures and queen to D7 she'll goes
after the H3 pawn and gcash says have at
it uh Rook to G1 so how do you how do
you continue here well as decided to
capture on H3 and now Bishop to D4 Gish
offers a second Pawn but this one you
cannot capture if you capture this one
then you run into Rook captures and G7
and after King captures Rook to G1 with
check and now the bishop pair from hell
is definitely fully operational king h8
queen to H6 and there is no defense
either you're going to play Queen to G7
Checkmate or even if you play something
like Rook to G8 even Queen captures an
H7 is Checkmate as the Knight on F6 is
pinned so G6 must be played here this is
what G played and now we have Queen to
F4 guarding the pawn on F3 but also
putting pressure on the F6 knight uh
Knight to H5 attacking the queen and now
Queen captures on
C7 uh and here the position is still
playable for black but you have to play
Bishop to F6 this sort of uh removes the
the The Rook from the task of defending
the bishop on E7 but he did not go for
Bishop to F6 he went for Queen captures
on F3 first but now gush plays Bishop to
B5 and now black has problems how do you
defend the rook and the bishop here H
best would be to play Queen F4 check and
just trade Queens H but it's still not
as simple because after Knight captures
F4 yes if you play Bishop captures and8
you have Knight the2 check also winning
the exchange but the Rook can simply
move and you still have the the same
problems here so uh white white will be
much better here uh but in the game
Queen captures an F3 was played and
after Bishop to B5 now Rook 8 to C8 was
played giving up another Pawn in order
to save the exchange Queen captures on
B7 and now Rook to B8 attacking guer
queen queen to A6 and now Rook e to d8
so saving saving the material but uh
keeping a very difficult position Bishop
to E2 attacking the queen we have Queen
to F4 with check Bishop to E3 and now
Queen to E5 and
here gkes has to figure out how to
continue he is now much better of course
and he can even play something like
Bishop captures an H5 remove material
from the board and then also pick up the
A7 pawn and he will have already two
connected pass pawns uh that are ready
to be pushed up the board however Queen
captures on A7 was played first and this
allowed Jil to play Knight to F4 which
reintroduces the Knight into the game uh
Bishop to F3 putting pressure on the D5
pawn and now comes Bishop to D6 and here
uh there are many moves you can play but
there is one that pretty much solves the
game for gkes and that is Queen to D4 it
was not played in the game which is
extremely relevant but just to show you
after Queen to D4 there's no move for
black it's just that bad of a position
whatever you play if you trade Queens
then uh something like Rook captures on
D4 uh then the Knight is hanging here so
you have to defend that and if you move
the Knight then you can also capture the
pawn here now you're now you're up two
pawns and you have three connected pass
pawns so there's no question about this
and if you don't trade Queens let's say
you want to avoid a queen trade still
doesn't help you Bishop to G4 and where
do you put your queen it's really not
not a lot of good squares here and again
if you trade it's really really bad so
that's uh the problem here you could
also go under the mask of The Rook but
that's no fun uh so yeah Queen to D4 was
just an amazing resource for gash here
but he played Rook to
D2 uh he he wanted to improve his
position first before going for any
captures and also he can now bring the
other Rook to D1 and just pick up the
pawn on D5 cleanly and that's it uh wrap
up the game this way but he missed a
great resource for Jill Mard and Jill
found it so feel free to pause the video
and figure out what gkes missed here
while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on realizing the
error of guer way uh his Rook on D2
blocks the D2 Square for his King and
that is crucial here and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Bishop captures an A3 here it's so
strong I can even do it in slow motion I
know you guys really love that yeah
Bishop captures an A3 and there's
nothing now for Gish to play if he
captures the bishop with the pawn it's a
matter of Queen captures on C3
threatening Queen the A1 Checkmate and
now if you play something like Bishop to
D4 to attack the queen and stop that now
Queen captures on F3 wins the bishop and
now you're you're just up material with
black and you have a much much better
position uh this is objectively uh
winning for for Jil Mard but after
Bishop captures on A3 if you play Queen
captures on A3 which looks like it could
solve all of your problems now comes
Rook to A8 attacking the White Queen if
you move the queen Rook to A1 is
Checkmate and if you don't move it I
mean you're going to lose the queen and
even if you try something like Bishop
captures and F4 threatening The Black
Queen still just Rook captures because
the Rook on D2 is blocking the the king
from escaping here whatever you play
Bishop captures an E5 Rook to A1 again
Checkmate so this Rook to d2 move uh
that Gish played it's hard to say but it
could could have been the worst possible
move that you you could have made on the
board it's uh I mean it it comes um uh
as a useful move if if black does not
have the resource of Bishop captures on
A3 but if he does then it's it's game
over for Gish now he played Rook to D4
he had to admit that the move was really
bad and now he freed up the D2 Square
for his King but it doesn't matter now J
just collects all of the material Bishop
captures some B2 King to D2 and now
Knight to E6 continuing in the strongest
way possible which is usually what
happens when you blunder then your
opponent you know all of a sudden uh he
he starts playing like an engine it's it
what always happens like uh I remember
in my tournament games like whenever I
made a mistake and then okay my opponent
took advantage of that mistake and I was
I was really resilient I wanted to fight
and I was like okay now he he he's bound
to make a mistake one in you know at
least one one mistake in 30 40 moves but
no of course they will play every move
and engine move uh but yeah okay Rook to
D3 was played now Bishop captures and C3
taking everything Rook captures and C3
D4 now attacking both rook and Bishop
Rook to D3 D captures on E3 with check
Queen captures on E3 three and now just
trading everything Queen captures on E3
Rook captures on D3 uh with check C
captures and now not going for a queen
trade but Knight to D4 and he was in
this position on move 33 that kukesh
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here of course if you if
you capture the Queen the Knight
captures on F3 lands a monster Fork here
a monster Royal fork and after the king
moves you will pick up the queen you're
going to be up a piece and if you don't
take the queen uh what else is there you
could play something like Rook to C1 but
then Rook to B2 check and you can't go
to the E file because then Knight
captures an F3 check and you cannot
capture due to the pin if you go King to
D1 it's not much better you just take
the queen and then you take the bishop
again you're up a full Knight so uh a
terrible terrible position for gkes who
who had a who had a completely winning
position but uh it's hard to imagine
like any move that he plays is good for
him does he play Bishop to C5 does he
trade this way does he bring the queen
to D4 does he bring the queen to to A4
sort of a a slow playing the position
and then to D4 even even this is
possible but this Rook to d2 move like I
said could be could be the worst
absolute absolute worst move on the
board and you know even even Gish is not
uh uh resistant to to those kind of
moves from time to time as it would seem
uh but yeah this is a pretty pretty big
blow for gcash as he needs to win this
event to qualify for the candidate
tournament and overtake Anish and Wesley
in the fiday fiday circuit and uh I
think think uh when I started recording
this game uh Michael Adams was still
playing this game but now I see that he
has drawn his game to Nikita vov and
that means that Adams is now leading the
tournament followed by two and a half
points there are gukesh Hans nean and
Jill Mard and next round gkes will be
facing U Michael Adams that will be that
will happen tomorrow and uh yeah we'll
see what happens in that one Gish will
have the blank pieces against the
tournament leader Michael Adams if he
can do it and if he wants be a member of
the candidates tournament 2024 then he
has to prove himself against the the
almighty Michael Adams uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it Gish
definitely hasn't this Rook to D2 will
be a painful one to fall asleep fall
asleep to but what are you going to do
that's chess it happens to everyone and
this time it happened to GES uh so yeah
once again really hope you guys enjoyed
it I would like to thank David gasparian
Dian Schwarz Robert quental sigurjon v v
mson and and gnome for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing with some more news and
action uh from the London chess classic
uh thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your
day